朋友們今天又要來我們一年一度的重磅視頻了就是2024全球經濟蓋欄幫大家梳理一下我總結出來的一個大的框架全球整體這一年發展的怎麼樣啊中國的經濟遇到了什麼樣的挑戰美國的經濟到底如何日本俄國阿根廷俄羅斯印度等等就是這麼個情況也會稍微加帶一些我自己的分析
我今天這個蓋了可能會跟你看到的大部分那種全球經濟盤點不太一樣。很多人可能會噹噹噹噹噹給你捋一遍2024年每個月都發生了什麼大事頭條。1月份怎麼了？2月份怎麼了？提完熱血費疼。但是可能缺少一些重點或者邏輯。也有一些比較專業的分析。一個表一個表給你挨個分析數據。這個確實是容易犯困。我是想盡量找到一個中間態。就邏輯上咱們也
看數據，看一些專業的分析，看到這個全貌和框架，同時盡量說人話，扔掉那些特別細緻目解，或者特別過於專業的數據。是不是感覺含金量還挺高的？反正我是努力過了。廢話少說，咱們開始。2024全球經濟蓋籃。噢噢噢噢噢噢。
24年之前，全球的經濟，雖然不能說陷入了衰退，但其實是處於一種非常動盪的狀態。你看又是疫情，俄烏戰爭，通貨膨脹，各國緊急加息。這就導致了一連串的危機，全球的供應鏈危機，歐洲的能源危機，美國的銀行業危機，日本的日元危機，英國的債務危機，中國的房地產危機，非洲的糧食危機等等等等。你敢想像嗎，這麼多危機，都集中發生在這兩年的時間裡。你這裡邊隨便單拎出來哪個個疫情之前，那可能都是一個核彈級別的危機了。
那現在呢，你看我們，晃晃悠悠，搖搖擺擺的，都挺過來了。之前發生的事兒，咱今天就不細說了。感興趣的朋友可以去看看這期視頻。而2024年呢，你想想，主要的一些政治經濟大事件呢，都只能說是事件，它不算雷。比如說美國大選，中國的大規模刺激，日本的加息，美聯儲的降息，這都只是個事兒。相比於之前的兩年，其實沒有那麼驚心動魄，可以說是相當的平穩。
GDP增長3.2%通貨膨脹進一步回落但是失業率有所上升所以2024年全球的經濟我總結一個詞有韌性我跟你說很多分析師都特別愛用這個詞聽起來特別高級有韌性的resilient相比什麼平庸一般我們叫有韌性它就有一種自我激勵的感覺
我們看2024年全球經濟它有兩個關鍵的主題一個是大選一個是轉向大選很好理解了2024年可以說是全球的一個大選年有至少70個國家覆蓋了全球49%的人口都進行了大選咱肯定不能一個一個說了大致上是有一些趨勢的
各國政府內部的分歧普遍加大了民粹主義普遍得到了增強整體更右翼了但是英國是個例外還有就是原來的執政黨它普遍在選舉裡表現的都不太好你比如說美國咱就不說了英國保守黨結束了14年的執政工黨贏得了壓倒性的多數它其實更左傾一點更大政府一點這個在全球算是個特例好這是大選2024年的另一大主題我們剛才說是轉向這個轉向我指的主要是政策方面的轉向
你看從23年的下半年開始全球的通脹開始緩和尤其是核心商品的通脹基本已經回歸了正常油價也降下來了只是服務的通脹它相對還比較高服務就是說你去剪個頭髮搓個澡這種因為畢竟它更滯後相對更有黏性一點
那在這種整體降溫的大背景下，大部分的經濟體也慢慢開始把這個煞車給鬆開了。2024年全球主要的37個央行裡，有27個都開始了降息週期。本來大家都是盯著美國，說美聯儲您量打，您先降，我們再一起跟上來。結果這美聯儲磨磨唧唧，本來以為他春天就要降息，結果好到立秋了還沒降。
其他國家都等不及了英國加拿大歐元區瑞士等等都開始降息美聯儲九月份了才發現咱好像降晚了咱得趕緊跟上第一次就降了五十個幾點
日本那邊正好反過來，沒降息，它是從持續了8年的負利率開始首次降息，這也是一個重大的轉向。而中國呢，雖然方向上沒有轉變，它是一直在降息，但從9月份開始，貨幣政策，財政政策都接連的發大招，開始加強刺激。中央的話語體系也有了一個明顯的轉變，這個也可以說是一種轉向。目前整體來看，大家的轉向畢竟都是第一步，相對都比較小心，也沒有出現什麼意料之外的結果。
大框架說完了咱們現在開始聚焦在每個經濟體的表現首先咱們來看看美國美國2024年GDP增長是2.8%23年和24年連續兩年都超過了市場的預期可以說是所有的發達經濟體裡面表現最亮眼的亮眼到大家都感覺有點不合理了不應該呀利率都加到這麼高了這個內需怎麼還能如此強勁這也是為什麼上回我們總結全球經濟的時候美國我用了個詞叫做莫名其妙現在還是用
原因可能是超額儲蓄就在疫情的時候大家存了一大撥錢也有可能是很多人在加息之前加了一撥槓桿貸款買房有可能是非法移民的湧入有可能是股票增長帶來的財富效應也有可能是所有這些因素的疊加總之就是美國的內需比較旺盛其實大家之前擔心的是什麼呢摩根大通特別愛用一個詞叫做溫水煮青蛙
什麼意思呢就是你把一個青蛙放在正在慢慢加熱的溫水裡他開始可能還覺得哎呀真暖和真舒服他還沒有意識到這個環境正在緩慢的不可逆的惡化而等到他感覺到燙燙燙的時候可能就已經晚了這個溫水呢摩根大通指的就是一個高利率的環境在這個環境下呢本來以為2024年可能會出現一些問題要麼是商業地產要麼是經濟上可能會出現明顯的下滑青蛙他會感覺到燙但實際上呢沒想到都沒有這也是為什麼美聯儲他憋到9月份才開始降息的一個主要原因
你看美國經濟這麼多數據裡頭有一個非常亮眼非常引人注目就是它的公司利潤2024年增長達到了7.7%美國企業的利潤率達到了70年以來的最高水平說白了就是疫情之後是美國公司二戰以來最賺錢的時候
你看這個是BlackRock對美國、歐洲和除日本以外亞洲企業這20年以來的利潤率的比較從08年之後明顯分化之前美國公司這麼能賺錢其實很大程度上是源自於互聯網行業的爆發不過這個不是我想說的重點我想說的重點是什麼呢你看疫情之後美國、歐洲的企業利潤率全都上漲了都更高了這是為什麼呢其實這裡頭很主要的一個原因就得歸功於通貨膨脹
你看原來歐美超低利率的時期這個通脹一直差不多是零一杯奶茶20塊錢它就永遠是20塊錢消費者心裡就清楚你這玩意就是20塊錢商家他就很難漲價所以很多時候被迫得壓縮自己的利潤
但這兩年物價一旦開始上漲，就變成是漲多點還是漲少點的問題。也就是說消費者心裡那個價格衡量的體繫有點失靈了，他對不同價格的接受度相對就會更高。你也不知道這玩意該多少錢。這時候企業就可以通過稍微多漲點價，去提高自己的利潤率。所以這裡頭確實有很大心理層面的問題。
你也可以說是企業佔了一些消費者心裡的便宜但是如果我們從整個經濟體的角度來看這些企業也會把多賺來的錢再重新放回到經濟體裡去加速整個經濟的運轉這也是為什麼現在大家普遍認為經濟它需要一定通脹的一個原因這還沒完你要知道企業的利潤率上升它會導致一個什麼結果呢就是它會增大美國的貧富差距
而且這些企業的利潤不是平均分配在各個公司頭上的而是越來越集中在頭部的大公司上以至於現在美國的經濟都可以說越來越綁定在這些超級大公司上你看10年前前10大市值的公司佔了美國標普500指數的18%現在已經翻倍佔到36%了也就是說就這麼10家公司佔了全球最主要股指的36%這可以說是非常恐怖的一個集中度了
而這裡面蘋果英偉大微軟就這三家公司就佔了20%所以最近五年企業家和打工人之間的貧富差距在拉大大企業和小企業他們之間的貧富差距也在拉大
這也是為什麼美國的經濟你看它數據很好看但很多美國人的體感並不明顯甚至是反過來的就感覺這兩年過的還沒有以前滋潤了畢竟你看像矽谷華爾街好萊塢都開始大規模裁員了這財富呢它就越來越集中在那最top的可能0.01%的人的手裡
好，咱再來說說他的貨幣政策。我們知道美聯儲的政策牽動著美元，美元又牽動著全球的金融市場。所以大家都緊盯著美聯儲，緊盯著鮑威爾的一舉一動。而鮑威爾他盯著什麼呢？最主要的就是美國的通脹和失業率。現在大致的情況就是通脹已經落到一個比較穩定的區間，有點正在一點一點被大家拋在腦後。所以美聯儲他關注的焦點就落在了失業率這。11月份是4.2%,一般感覺如果是在4.5%以下，他大概率就不會影響到美聯儲降息的節奏。
其實這回美聯儲降息大概率也不會像兩年之前加息一樣掀起全球資本的滔天巨浪。為什麼呢？一方面是當時加息加的非常突然，市場都沒有預期。其次當時加息的幅度也非常短，從零一直加到5.5%,加了500多個基點。而現在這個降息週期已經降到4.75%,最終大家預期大概率會降到3.5%左右，就不太會再回到2%以下甚至是零的那個時代了。所以它剩的空間大概也就剩100來個基點。
然後啊咱們來說一說接下來特朗普2.0時代他可能的一些政策基本上呢就這麼幾個大方向稅收減免去監管化貿易保護還有移民收緊
這些政策總體對美國經濟的影響和好的方面比如說它會刺激整體的經濟刺激整體的需求同時有利於資本回流美國另外比較利多美元利多股市尤其是傳統能源和金融業還有就是利多比特幣你看特朗普一當選好傢伙比特幣從7萬直接飆到10萬很多人猜測一個重要的原因就是市場預期特朗普的監管政策可能會對比特幣比較有利潛在的一些負面影響首先就是再通脹的風險你看它的貿易政策移民政策都有可能會引發通脹的死灰復燃
當然特朗普也給出自己的解決方案他就是說要通過增加石油供給來穩定物價不過從市場的反應來看大家對這個還是有一些擔心的特朗普當選之後這個聯邦利率的期貨價格在下降其實就是因為市場擔心二次通脹的風險會增加美聯儲的降息節奏就會更慢利息利率就會上升所以期貨價格它就下降
還有就是像貿易政策、移民政策，它其實會增加美國經濟的不確定性。你想特朗普推出了關稅政策之後，別的國家也不可能就那麼乾坐著對吧，他肯定也會反擊。至於怎麼政策怎麼反擊，這不就不確定了嗎？不過單就美國對中國加徵關稅而言，這個不確定性其實不太會增大。同時對市場的影響預期也不會很大，因為中國包括美國自己的商家其實都做好這個心理準備，都不光是心理準備也做好了充足的準備了。
這就和克朗普第一次上臺那時候貿易戰剛開始的時候完全不一樣了你看那時候中國佔美國總進口的20%現在這個數字已經降到13%了雙方其實都做好了分手的準備當然我們說分手可能都不太準確你看全球現在分工這麼精細化他想做到完全分手其實也不太可能比如說你看哈佛商學院的這篇論文它經過了一大通量化分析相關性分析
就得出了一個很簡單的結論就是很多原來從中國進入到美國的商品在貿易戰之後變成了從墨西哥、越南等等國家繞了一圈再進入美國所以現在並不完全是去全球化一部分是叫做Great reallocation就是一個大重購而這個大重購它的直接受益人是誰呢？可能是墨西哥和越南
接下來2025年，大部分的分析師他們覺得美國的經濟不會像之前兩年那麼堅挺了。IMF預測它的GDP增速會回落到2.2%。不過有一個點是之前兩年炒得非常熱的一個風險，也是市場擔心美國潛在最大的風險。不過這兩年它正在逐漸的弱化或者說消失，是什麼呢？就是美國的商業地產。
我覺得不是說這個風險在弱化就不說了還是有必要稍微解釋解釋這個商業地產危機是什麼意思呢我給你舉個例子
你比如說紐約有一個樓，1407 Broadway,它是個辦公樓寫字樓。這種樓一般會選擇發債，去回籠資金，然後撬動更大的槓桿。它在2019年就發了3.5億美元的債。因為它地理位置在曼哈頓非常非常中心的區域，你放之前根本不愁租不出去。所以這個債券的評級是3A級，就是最高級，比美國國債評級都要高。結果疫情之後，租不出去了。24年6月就說，不好意思各位，我付不起利息了，違約了。
你要知道好像3A級債券它的違約概率是要小於千分之一的。得，就讓這個1407 Broadway的投資人給趕上了。而且我跟你說，這個樓的情況不是一個個例。大部分商業地產的債券都多多少少會存在著這個風險。就讓整個CNBS的市場都陷入了這種混亂。而這裡邊損失最慘重的是誰呢？就是美國的一些中小銀行。有超過一萬億美元的商業地產債券或者貸款是美國的中小銀行持有的。如果中小銀行爆雷的話，就可能會發生類似之前硅谷銀行那種事件。
這個就是之前市場擔心美國比較大的一個潛在危機現在隨著時間的推移雖然這個風險還沒有解除這些損失也確實是時大時的發生了但是引發整個經濟連鎖反應的這個概率是大大降低了因為什麼呢因為他們熬到了美聯儲降息投資市場就會一點一點的升溫那種銀行業的大規模的爆雷大概率是不會出現在美聯儲降息的這個週期裡的要我說現在美國最大的潛在危機就是它的國債
你這麼控制不住一點一點增加這才是最大的溫水煮青蛙你看國會兩黨三天兩頭就炒一次價你總有更緊急的事情需要擴大財政預算需要擴大支出需要提高債務上限這個水就這麼一點一點的加熱烘的裡面的青蛙挺暖和的現在倒是這個說實在的它短期內不會有什麼太大的爆雷不過咱不得不提一嘴剛才這些就是關於美國的經濟我提煉出來的一些點接下來咱們來看一看日本
2024年IMF估算日本GDP增長是0.3%日本從各項數據的角度來看經濟可以說是非常的平庸什麼東西正0.幾負0.幾都在這個正負1%上下浮動不過雖說從數據上來看它這個增長可以說是幾乎沒有但它實際的經濟是在好轉的此話怎講呢其實日本的經濟它是有一點畸形的
你看過去這二三十年因為持續的內需不足通貨緊縮企業的利潤率下降央行就強行注入大量的流動性政府強行拒借海量的債務相當於是強行拖起來整個經濟你看它的貨幣政策之前不光是負利率而且央行買入了760萬億日元的資產也就是超過5萬億美元的量你看美聯儲那麼能買也就不超過7萬億美元但日本經濟什麼體量它的GDP才不到美國的六分之一它央行買的量跟美國差不多你想想
所以日本基本上半個市場都是靠它央行印錢給強行拖起來的可能很多人這麼多年都已經有點習慣了日本經濟這個特殊性習慣了它的機型算什麼數吧都得除去日本excluding Japan不過2024年這個情況終於看到了轉變你看企業的利潤率也在上漲股市也在持續上漲最關鍵的是它終於等到了夢寐以求的通貨膨脹
所以日本的央行在2024年終於要開始退出這種畸形的政策。之前幾年日本的經濟很多是靠政府和央行的強心計在那撐著，不過24年終於有點靠自己了。這就是為什麼我說，雖然它數據看著可能沒有那麼亮眼，但是市場普遍看好它的原因。IMF預計它在2025年的GDP增長率會增長到1.1%,這對日本來說已經不低了。
日本跟其他經濟體最不一樣的地方就是它的貨幣政策跟別人是反著的你看現在全球都在降息就日本央行它在加息其實並不是說它就非要跟人家唱反調只是說它比別人要滯後滯後了大概兩年的時間你看前兩年全球的通脹都起來暴風雨來了報表都嚇得直哆嗦幾乎所有人都避之不及開始瘋狂加息
只有日本真是久旱逢甘霖那個舒服那個美啊人家到這邊在這狂狂假期就日本在這享受讓這個通脹來的更猛烈一些吧當然了日本央行它也不能一直任由通脹這麼失控這麼一直漲下去只是它需要看到工資也開始上漲看到工資跟物價螺旋上漲這個循環產生了它才會決定開始要假期所以日本央行它現在關注的一個重點就是工資咱之前也聊過日本這個工資它不是說漲就漲的它有一個叫做
每年春天大公司會跟公會有一個全國性的大談判。春天就來鬥一鬥。這個春鬥的結果就決定了這一年各大公司員工工資的漲幅。2024年的談判結果是33年以來日本工資的最大漲幅。這也是為什麼日本央行非常果斷地加息的一個主要原因。接下來日本央行加息的節奏還要看春鬥，就是2025年的春鬥。
現在呢日本的央行已經從負利率加息加到了0.25%十年期的利率已經超過了1%這個利率曲線呢正在正常化當然它的資產負債表還是非常的龐大預計2025年又會開始縮表而這個眾人皆將唯我獨家這個情況會導致什麼結果呢就是大量的日本海外資產會迴流那反過來現在可能就需要擔心一下如果日元升值過快就出口的影響好日本我們就說這麼多啊再來說歐洲
歐洲可以說是全球經濟增長比較弱的一環了2024年大概是0.9%2025年估計也差不多其中尤其是德國一直以來都是歐洲算是最堅實的一環但2024年萎縮了0.1%而且這不是他第一年萎縮了2023年就已經萎縮了0.3%從疫情之前2019年底到現在德國GDP累計的實際增長是零在所有發達國家裡是墊底的不過挺有意思的一點是什麼你要非較真的話德國的經濟其實還並沒有完全陷入衰退
因為這個經濟衰退一般定義是什麼？是說你這個GDP要連續兩個季度都是負增長。而你看德國最近兩年每個季度的GDP增長，你看漲一下跌一下，漲一下跌一下，只不過你漲的都比跌的要少。但是我從來沒有連續兩個季度跌，所以我也不算陷入衰退。開個玩笑，其實現在沒有人去否認說德國陷入了衰退，陷入了泥潭。咱來看看他的問題在哪？
首先從最表面的說德國確實受到能源危機的影響最大這是兩年前最直接的當頭一棒然後就是他的財政政策注意這也是個重點他在財政方面非常的保守你看他現在面臨的各種經濟困難這要放美國人早就全民罰錢了可是德國人呢他就非常的一板一眼我們是有原則的政府說不能亂花錢就不能亂花錢他就把這個財政勒的緊緊的
他在2009年的時候通過了一項法案，俗稱的叫《債務剎車法案》。他就規定聯邦政府的結構性赤字不能超過GDP的0.35%。你看0.35,這是一個可以說是非常苛刻的要求，就是說你政府不能有財政赤字。而且德國人做事真的是非常有規矩，這個《債務剎車法案》是直接放在憲法裡頭的。
現在呢其實也並不是說所有德國人都不想刺激他執政黨的內部就出現了一些分歧你看他現在的執政黨是由三個黨組成的一個聯盟結果自己內部打起來了經濟部長哈貝克他是綠黨這邊的他就覺得我們應該修改憲法允許在財政上去花錢
而財政部這邊呢是自由黨，他們就覺得不亂花錢是天經地義，是神聖而不可侵犯的。他們這個意見分歧就越鬧越大，結果在11月份的時候，哎，談崩了。總理舒爾茨就罷免了這個財政部長，就是自由黨這邊主張不能亂花錢那個。這也成為了德國歷史上第一次三黨聯盟出現了失控的情況，然後他們要在2025年的2月提前進行大選。
就這麼看，2025年德國應該會要開始財政赤字去刺激經濟了。其實我覺得吧，德國這種比較保守的財政政策，從長期來看並不一定是個壞事。只不過呢，短期確實會讓德國的經濟數據比較難看。阻礙德國經濟增長的除了財政以外，還有一個非常主要的，就是人口。
我估計很多朋友一聽到人口問題可能都有點應激了最近這幾年哪個星期提出問題你都跟我說是人口問題中國有人口問題日本也人口問題韓國也人口問題印度也人口問題現在說到德國你又給我來人口問題我跟你說德國這個人口問題它確實也有它的特殊性它確實是可以解釋它的短期現象的你其實看看它這個人口結構圖估計你就get了
你看這塊是有一個非常非常明顯的人口高峰，大概是在60歲左右。注意這個是他2020年的人口統計結果，所以他應該在往上挪四年。德國他在1960年代的時候有一波非常非常大的嬰兒潮，比大部分其他國家都猛。而這些人正在大批量的退休，大批量的退出勞動市場。當然德國他的退休年齡比較短，是在66到67歲。所以理論上他的退休高峰應該是在2030年左右。而且即使這兩年這些勞動力還沒有退休，
但他們已經60多歲了又剛剛經歷了疫情的洗禮你指望他們多生產力旺盛是吧而我們再看他這些要步入社會的或者剛剛步入社會的年輕人是在持續下滑的也就是說這兩年德國的勞動力不光是在削減而且是在加速削減這其實也解釋了德國的兩個現象一個呢是這兩年德國的工資加速上升
一方面也有大環境通貨膨脹的原因，但同時也來自於德國它自身勞動力非常短缺。另一個現象就是這兩年德國的生產力，你看到它是明顯下滑的。你看這是最近美國的生產力，它長這樣，而德國長這樣，是吧？
現在全球的經濟是在面臨轉型的而德國的產業它其實是已經高度成熟高度定型的而勞動力市場的內部它又在飛速地老齡化你看這些五六十歲的勞動力當年都是幫德國經濟打下天下的功臣但同時也意味著它現在轉型其實是比較困難比較費勁的
你比如說大眾、博士、德國鐵路現在都要裁員這些被裁掉的高技術人才他要找新的工作相對於其他國家就沒那麼容易了總之德國現在確實比較麻煩面臨的都是比較底層的結構性問題你看結構性的能源短缺結構性的勞動力短缺對油車的結構性需求下滑政府也可以說是結構性的死板你什麼都結構性那你遇到困難的時候自然恢復的速度就會比較慢
好 接下來咱們來看一看中國的經濟中國前三季度的GDP增速分別是5.3% 4.7%和4.6%第四季度使勁努一努的話還是有可能實現經濟增速全年5%的這個目標不過呢咱還是別太糾結於這個數字咱主要還是看事看邏輯和應對的政策這個比較重要
這一年裡出口是表現最亮眼的部分尤其是24年的第三季度GDP增長有接近一半都是經出口拉動的你看很多企業24年的熱詞就是出海對吧一方面是海外需求的回升另一方面也是很多其他國家都進入了新一輪的叫補庫存軸期什麼意思呢就說23年它用的基本還是存貨所以中國23年出口就一般了24年新一輪又該進貨了中國這個經出口就跟著上來
然後表現一般的方面就是投資。其實基建和製造業的投資增長還是挺猛的。主要就是受了地產投資的拖累。所以整體的投資就可以說是拉平吧。然後表現比較弱的就是消費了。
中國經濟在24年其實很主要的一個問題就是內需不足信心不足連帶著物價也跟著下來了PPI已經連續兩年多在零以下了而且就業市場也在收縮很多公司都在講究降本增效這也是為什麼快到年底了一系列的財政政策貨幣政策在接連放大招這個不急我們一會兒細聊效果呢我總結就是短期有所改善總體成效還有待考察
長期增長點還需挖掘。怎麼樣，我最近也是惡補了一下形容中國經濟的這個話語體系。怎麼說的，滴水不漏。現在可以說消費是帶動中國經濟齒輪重新加速轉動的一個核心了。咱來看看這個政策是怎麼刺激消費的。
其實早在2022年底，國務院就發布了《擴大內需戰略規劃綱要》。不過2023年的一些政策，主要是集中在綠色能源、消費轉型上，還很少有那種實打實的花錢去刺激的政策。但是到2024年，它就又進一步了。我總結，對消費有刺激作用的，主要有這麼兩個。一個是發行超長期特別國債。第二個是降低存量放貸利率。你是不是聽著感覺，
這跟消費好像也沒什麼關係啊。你說發國債怎麼就刺激消費了？這個降低存量房貸利率按理講是刺激房地產市場的，跟消費有什麼關係呢？你別急，再來一個又說。
什麼叫做存量房貸利率呢就是這些已經貸款買房的人已經開始按揭還貸的人你們合同都已經簽好了但是這個利率我給你下調國內的房貸利率呢一般是LPR加上一個利差的形式比如說LPR加上30個基點好那把它降低我就直接給你變成LPR比如減成30個基點從今往後不管你是10年期的貸款還是30年期的貸款
每年房貸利率都相當於減少了60個幾點每年的利息都相當於少還0.6%所以你看本來這個貸款它就是一個浮動利率了我還在這個浮動的基礎之上再把利息降低來減輕你還貸的壓力這真的相當於是從銀行嘴裡把這個錢給你扣出來去給貸款人進行補貼了據估算這個政策平均給現有房貸的降幅大概是50個幾點讓全國人民平均每年少付了大概是1500億人民幣
這樣呢就讓本來有一些可能被房貸勒著限制消費的人有一部分的流動性可以釋放出來恢復消費。所以說降低這個存量房貸利率釋放這1500億每年最直接刺激的其實不是房地產市場因為這些人房子已經買了而是消費。另一個刺激消費相關的政策就是超長期特別國債。什麼叫超長期特別國債呢？
就是期限特別長的一般在十年以上有特殊用途的國債它是不計入政府的財政赤字的這種國債只有在特殊時期特殊用途才會去增發比如說上一回是20年的時候抗金疫情發行了一萬億24年總共又發行了一萬億的超長期特別國債
那這回的特殊目的是什麼呢？這裡有7000億是負責兩重主要就是基建另外的3000億叫兩新就是推動新一輪大規模設備更新和消費品的已舊換新後面這3000億裡頭很主要的一部分就是為了刺激消費比如你點進去淘寶京東上面很重要的一欄就寫著國家補貼或者有一些大件你點進去它就寫著
已舊換新，國補，這些都是這三千億裡面這部分帶動的。目前看來推動最大的就是對家電領域的消費。那國家為什麼會選擇用已舊換新的形式而不是直接去補貼消費呢？首先你看它起到了補貼消費的作用。同時我去刺激你的是換新，對吧？因為很多剛需大家其實已經都解決了。而我刺激出來的就是這種改善性的需求。在同時也會帶動回收再利用的產業鏈，也帶動了投資。
不過總體來說，市場上普遍認為，這個消費刺激政策的體量只能說是小石牛刀。你想中國一年可能得有大概50萬億體量的消費。很多分析師都在期待能有更大力度的消費相關的刺激。這個應該是很能直接提振GDP的一個方向。好，咱再來說說地產。
這部分大家其實已經達成了一個共識就現在還在一個非常深度的調整期房地產投資22年23年24年每年都大概下降10%不管是新房還是二手房的銷量包括房價都在持續下降而房價的下跌它會影響地方政府的資產負債表會影響到銀行的資產負債表也會影響到購房者自己的資產負債表進而連帶的影響著整個經濟所以不難理解房地產市場的恢復它需要非常長的一段時間
這個大家應該都比較清楚，我們就不多多解釋了。咱們來看看房地產市場對應的一些刺激政策。24年上半年比較大的就是這個517新政了，就是在5月17號發布的一連串的刺激政策。最直接的就是刺激需求端相關的政策，比如說降低房貸利率，降低首付比例，降低限購的標準，降低購房相關的稅費等等。這些都是比較正常的刺激需求端的政策。
同時還有一個刺激政策很有意思。他推出了一個3000億的叫保障性住房債貸款。我跟你說你一聽這種債貸款、債貼現、債抵押、債怎麼怎麼招這種詞。它一般就都和央行有關。央行通過銀行再怎麼招就叫債什麼政策。那這個保障性住房債貸款它什麼意思呢？簡單來說就是央行它把這個錢貸款給銀行。然後銀行再貸給各個地方的國企去直接買房。然後國企把這些房子租出去或者改成保障性的住房。
其實說白了就是，央行牽頭發錢去買房，直接拖起房地產市場，看看能不能把地產商、把銀行的資金鏈給盤活。你看到沒有，這個刺激方式是非常直接的，也是很多分析師會看好整個鏈條運作的一個方式。但它其實在實施過程中具體能不能實現這個效果，還有很多操作性的問題需要解決。
因為現在你看需求端的刺激降低各種利率比例刺激大家買房的政策其實已經都放得差不多了它的邊際效應是在遞減大家貸款的意願買房的意願還是非常的弱所以之後下一步的刺激空間從哪來呢就是政府或者央行直接主導下場去買從供給側去把這個問題解決
只不過呢這個三千億的體量啊它確實也不大就跟剛才我們說以舊換新的那個三千億差不多這個體量只能算作是小試牛刀如果試下來這個流程確實比較順利這個錢能流到該流的地方把該盤子都給盤活那二五年呢很有可能會擴大這個債債款的規模好接下來咱們來梳理一下從九月份往後央行政府推出的一系列自給政策和它大致的一個邏輯不然你看新聞今天一個重磅明天一個頭條你要是都
不清楚框架很容易被一些重磅給炸懵了我大概會把它分成這麼幾個方向財政政策、貨幣政策、房地產刺激政策和股市的刺激政策財政政策裡最猛的就是11月份推出的地方政府10萬億加的化債方案簡單來說就是地方政府你不是債務纏身嗎中央我就出錢幫你拖一拖不著急慢慢緩但是咱不能違約這個化債10萬億的規模聽起來還是很大的如果大家感興趣我們可以單開一期來聊這個化債
貨幣政策主要就是降息降準還推出了一些新的工具比如說買斷式逆回購這個我們就不詳細解釋了簡單來說就是往市場去注入流動性住房的刺激政策我們剛才其實也說差不多了下半年就是說會比517新政再進一步的從需求端去加大力度而股市方面央行還是動了動腦筋推出了很多那種名字非常繞的政策工具你比如說證券基金保險公司互換便利繞吧我跟你說它英文更繞叫
SFISF它有5000億的額度大概就是說這些金融公司可以把自己手上的股票質押給央行換成流動性更好的國債這些國債你可以去市場上賣掉賣到回來的錢只能去買股票其實說白了就是幫助一些國家隊的資本拿到更多的資金然後去支撐股市
還有像什麼股票回購，增持專項再貸款，其實就是公司可以直接找央行借錢去回購股票。總之這些創新的方式，都是把錢從央行那轉轉轉轉，然後丟向股市。大致是這些方向。
你看前兩年雖然政府也在刺激央行也在降息但整體這個態度上是處在一個穩健的狀態而這回這波刺激政策就不一樣了貨幣政策財政政策一大片好拉起手來搓了一個連爪是吧這個力度可想而知是非常大的不過即使是這些市場的反
明白，有，但是也沒有那麼高漲，就好像還沒滿足到很多人希望的那個刺激力度。因為說實話，政府這邊還沒有使盡全力把所有的彈藥都打出來，它還是有很大的空間的。你就比如說這一輪最大規模的這個花債解決方案，它其實是屬於一個穩定性的政策，而不是一個刺激性的政策。
他更大的目的就是先讓你穩住這好比什麼呢就比如說你的信用卡下個禮拜該還款該到期了那銀行就跟你說你不著急我再給你三個月的時間你自己先想想辦法這個呢就屬於穩定性的政策對吧給你更多時間先把你穩住而刺激性的政策呢就是說銀行
他開始幫你想辦法幫你聯繫人幫你找工作幫你掙錢來還這個信用卡這顯然在正常情況下是不應該的對吧你自己欠錢了就應該自己想辦法還但現在這種特殊情況呢很多人他也沒招了只能眼巴巴的瞅著央行說你那邊幫幫我對吧
好，剛才咱說的這種刺激性的政策，其實政府在2024年已經開始嘗試了。比如之前我們提到的移舊換新，房地產市場的再貸款，股票市場的再貸款，什麼互換便利等等，這些都是最直接的刺激政策。只不過還是在3000億、5000億，大概這個規模和體量。而12月份剛剛開的經濟工作會議，就給2025年的政策定調了。雖然還沒有特別具體的實施的政策，但基本的基調就是開閘放水，全面刺激。
市場預計呢，央行會更快的降息，更多的去買國債。政府這邊的財政赤字也會增加，至少會從24年的3%升高到4%,也會發更多的超長期特別國債，讓房地產市場止跌回穩，要大力提振消費。
好，這個大概就是2024年中國經濟整體的概況和大概的政策方向。對了，可能很多人會比較關心人民幣的走勢。這個我看大部分券商的預測還是比較統一的。面對特朗普的貿易戰，加上中國央行也在更快速的降息放稅。央行有可能會放手，允許人民幣適當的走弱，來刺激出口，刺激物價，對沖貿易戰帶來的衝擊。其他國家，咱們挑稍微有意思一點的，快速瞭解一下。
這個是各國2024年實際GDP增長率的一個排名我篩選了那些稍微大一點的GDP超過3000億美元的經濟體這裡頭增長最快的還是印度
從絕對增長來看，印度可以說是這幾年全球表現最好的經濟體。2023年GDP增速8.2%,非常亮眼。2024年下滑到7.0%,但也是非常好的。很多人可能會覺得印度的崛起那肯定是中美貿易戰，讓印度吃到了紅地。我跟你說，還真不是。印度對外資的態度，不管是對美國還是對中國，其實……
都不是特別好它主要的增長其實包括很多東南亞國家這幾年主要的增長還是源於它的內需不過拉動印度內需的其實並不是消費而是投資包括政府的基建投資它現在還是處在一個政府可以大搞基建怎麼投怎麼有投資回報率很高的這樣一個階段不過呢最近印度它也有通脹再次抬頭的風險24年的四季股突然開始反彈也是它現在比較大的一個風險
俄羅斯的經濟24年表現得非常強韌雖然受到了西方的全面制裁但是23年和24年它的GDP增速都達到了3.6%非常籠統的說一方面是靠堅挺的能源價格另一方面政府也在全力的去刺激不過24年前三個季度本來都挺好的到第四季度盧布突然開始加速下跌俄羅斯的通脹也開始再度上升你發現沒有好像所有的經濟體幾乎都是四季度開始出現了變化也不知道這怎麼全世界人民到90月份就開始亢奮起來了
通脹一上來，俄羅斯的政策就開始有點擰巴了。一方面，政府的財政政策，包括國企使勁的刺激擴大投資。另一方面，央行又一個勁在那使勁的加息，現在利率已經加到了21%,這就好比說像一輛車，一邊給它油門踩到底，另一邊又拉著手剎，給它使勁剎著車，這不就很擰巴嗎？這也可以說給接下來的2025年照上了一層霧霾。
IMF預計俄羅斯2025年的GDP增速會下滑到1.3%。咱們之前聊過一期俄羅斯的經濟。有機會，其實咱也可以再分析分析戰後的俄羅斯經濟。不知道大家感不感興趣。英國24年GDP增長是1.1%。增長也降下來了，到3%以下。失業率4.3%。可以說基本上是恢復到了一個正常發展的模式。反正整體比歐盟恢復的還稍微快一點。
土耳其之前一直是飽受通貨膨脹的灼燒在它持續50%的利率下下半年這個通脹終於是被壓下來但同時被壓下來的還有它的GDP增長率韓國24年GDP預期增長是2.5%很主要是靠出口在拉動它的內需還是比較萎靡的內部也就是靠政府支出在支撐
阿根廷24年的經濟增長全球墊底當然我說的是3000以上這些比較大的經濟體基本上完全是靠出口成長其他所有的經濟指標都是負增長而且是特別負的增長
整體內需萎縮了12%而出口的增長很大程度上也是得利於它貨幣的貶值聽著很糟糕是吧不過說實話讓我用一個詞來形容阿根廷的經濟叫情有可原為什麼呢因為阿根廷它正在進行一個非常大膽非常徹底的改革甚至可以說是一個經濟實驗就是休克療法
你看阿根廷這兩年一直面臨著非常嚴重的經濟困難通脹飆升貨幣貶值政府腐敗嚴重等等二三年底阿根廷就選出來一個風格完全不一樣的極右翼的總統米萊他的政策主張就是小政府甚至有人說他是一個無政府主義者你就應該讓經濟完全自由
之前政府不是控制不住亂花錢嗎？不是腐敗嗎？那沒有用的部門我就全給你砍掉。就這半年裡，他把政府原來有18個部門，砍成了8個。什麼補貼、極限項，全停掉。就是要把政府給縮小縮小再縮小。你別跟他霍華跟停經濟了，你就要放手讓市場區自由發展，來煥發他的活力。
米萊真的第一年就讓政府實現了盈餘並且嚴格控制貨幣供給通貨膨脹率從300%愣時壓到了160%你看這些都是非常激進的緊縮政策所以它經濟受到衝擊其實是必然的這也是為什麼我說它叫情有可原其實米萊這個休克療法還沒結束他就說2025年要給大家減稅90%還要逐漸放寬外匯管制等等
其實阿根廷的經濟從2024年的三季度就已經開始慢慢好轉而且米萊跟特朗普關係還特別好所以很多人預測特朗普上臺之後阿根廷的經濟會受益市場預計阿根廷會在2025年迅速反彈IMF就預計他的GDP增速會達到35%還有一個小國他的GDP雖然沒到3000億美元這個級別不過我也來說一下他這幾年好像是連續在全球GDP增速裡面排名榜首可以說是一個一夜暴富的國家就是圭亞納
它是南美洲北邊只有75萬人口的一個小國和石油大戶委內瑞拉緊挨著之前就只能眼巴巴看著人家在那攥油結果2015年的時候它自己也發現了大量的油田2019年開始商業開採之後好傢伙就好像活到30歲了突然發現自己是個富二代就開始了歸亞納的開掛人生啊不是 開掛國生你看人家GDP都是5%10%就頂大天了而歸亞納過去5年平均的GDP增速是40%
人均GDP從6000美元增長到了3萬美元已經跟沙特一個級別了你再過兩年做到什麼全球領先那都不好說呀所以大家一定要記住這個國家歸亞納人家現在也是個土豪國家你看啊，咱看了這麼多國家的經濟我有一個挺有意思的想法你看這各個國家的經濟它是不是就有點像大家開著輛車在那比賽前兩年全球的通貨膨脹一起來
大家這車都有點過熱了都快著了拼命的在那踩煞車降溫這美國呢本身就開的比較快處於領先地位快得有點莫名其妙了踩了這煞車央行都加息了但還一個勁往前衝同時呢最近又要上來一個新司機就想要開呢離別的車都遠點不能讓別的車搭我們美國的順風車甚至我還得給別的車扔點技能搞點路障什麼的
而日本這輛車30年前曾經急駛過風光過然後起火了這慢慢又有故有故有故有了二三十年一直打不著火好不容易最近給點著了感覺可以起速了這發動機可能感覺雖然有點熱但也沒事最近24年剛剛開始青菜剎車
中國雖然原來的位置比較靠後但是開的賊快一路各種超車最近就發現這個發動機就原來房地產那套好像沒那麼好用了咱得升級引擎了不過因為原來速度很快所以還能靠著慣性往前再出溜出溜一邊出溜一邊趕緊找新的引擎新的發動機
而德國就屬於一板一眼開著一個非常穩健的老爺車行駛了三四十年最近這個老爺車熄火了更麻煩的是車裡的人吵起來了有些人就覺得你得趕緊使勁採油門使勁採油門有些人就覺得你不能太著急咱得一起來修車看看到底哪出了問題反正就是每輛車都有自己的問題不過總體的感覺是最艱難的時候就是大部分經濟體集體踩煞車的時候已經過去了2024年政策掛檔轉向總體還是比較平穩的
現在又回到了大部分車開始重新踩油門的階段開始新一輪的加槓桿所以2025年全球整體經濟的預測還是比較樂觀的要說最大的不確定性我覺得一方面肯定是特朗普的貿易政策和他帶來的連鎖的反應再有一個就是中國的消費借貸能不能有起色
這些就是我們對2024年全球經濟的一個總結。非常感謝大家能夠非常耐心的看到這。如果你有什麼補充想要討論的，也歡迎在評論區留言。朋友們，我們2025年再見！